once every 12 months the world's largest
human migration happens in China over
the 40 day travel period of Chinese New
Year three billion trips are taken as
families reunite and celebrate now the
most strenuous of these trips are taken
by the country's 290 million migrant
workers for many of whom this is the one
chance a year to go home and see parents
and they left behind children but the
travel options are very limited plane
tickets cost nearly half of their
monthly salary so most of them they
choose to train their average journey is
700 kilometres the average travel time
is 15 and a half hours and the country's
tracks now have to handle 390 million
travelers every Spring Festival until
recently migrant workers would have to
queue for long hours sometimes days just
to buy tickets often only to be fleeced
by scalpers and they still had to deal
with near Stampede conditions when
travel day finally arrived but
technology has started to ease this
experience mobile and digital tickets
now account for 70% of sales greatly
reducing the lines at strain stations
digital ID scanners have replaced manual
checks expediting the boarding process
and artificial intelligence is deployed
across the network to optimize travel
routes new solutions have been invented
China's largest taxi hailing platform
it's called Dede true xin launched a new
service called hitch which matches car
owners are driving home with passengers
looking for long-distance routes and
just its third year hitch served 30
million trips in this past holiday
season the longest of which was further
than 1500 miles that's about the
distance from Miami to Boston this
enormous need of migrant workers has
powered fast upgrade and innovation
across the country's transport systems
now the Chinese internet it has
developed in both familiar and
unfamiliar ways just like in Silicon
Valley some of the seismic shifts in
technology and consumer behavior have
been driven by academic
research have been driven by enterprise
desires with the whims of privilege and
you sprinkled in every once in a while I
am a product of the American tech
industry both as a consumer and a
corporate leader so I am well-acquainted
with this type of fuel but about a year
and a half ago I moved from my home in
New York City to Hong Kong to become the
CEO of the South China Morning Post and
from this new vantage point I've
observed something that is far less
familiar to me propelling so much of
China's innovation and many of its
entrepreneurs it is an overwhelming need
economy that is serving an
underprivileged populace which has been
separated for thirty years from China's
economic boom the stark gaps that exist
between the rich and the poor between
urban and rural or the academic and the
unschooled these gaps think they form a
soil that's ready for some incredible
empowerment so when capital and
investment become focused on the needs
of people who are hanging to the bottom
runs of an economic ladder that's when
we start to see the internet truly
become a job creator and education and a
blur and in many other ways a path
forward of course China is not the only
place where this alternative fuel exists
nor the only place where it is possible
but because of the country's sheer scale
and status as a rising superpower the
needs of its population have created an
opportunity for truly compelling impact
when explaining the rapid growth of the
Chinese tech industry many observers
will cite two reasons the first is the
1.4 billion people that call China home
the second is the government's active
participation or pervasive intervention
depending on how you view it now the
central authorities have spent heavily
on network infrastructure over the years
creating an attractive environment for
investment the same time they've
insisted on standards and regulation
which has led to fast consensus and
therefore fast adoption the world's
largest pool of tech talent exists
because of the abundance of educational
incentives
and local domestic companies in the past
have been protected from international
competition by market controls of course
you cannot observe the Chinese internet
without finding widespread censorship
and very serious concerns about
dystopian monitoring as an example China
is in the process of rolling out a
social credit rating that will cover its
entire population rewarding and
restricting citizens based on highly
qualitative characteristics like honesty
and integrity at the same time China is
deploying facial recognition across many
of its 170 million closed-circuit
cameras artificial intelligence is being
used to predict crime and terrorism in
chingon province where the Muslim
minority is already under constant
surveillance
yet the Internet has continued to grow
and it is so big much bigger than I
think most of us realize by the end of
2017 the Chinese internet population had
reached 772 million users it's larger
than the populations of the United
States and Russia of Germany of the
United Kingdom of France and Canada
combined 98% of them are active on
mobile 92% of them used messaging apps
there are now 650 million digital news
consumers 580 million digital video
consumers and the country's largest
e-commerce platform pal ball now boasts
580 million monthly active users it's
about 80 percent larger than Amazon on
demand travel between bikes and cars now
account for 10 billion trips a year in
China that's two-thirds of all trips
taken around the world so it's a very
mixed bag the internet exists in a
restricted arguably manipulated form
within China yet it is massive and has
vastly improved the lives of its
citizens so even in its imperfection the
growth of the Chinese Internet should
not be dismissed and it's worthy of our
closer examination let me tell you two
other stories today Lords ollio is a 34
year old engineer from Jiang Shi
Province
now his home region used to be
important to the Communist Party because
this was the birthplace of the Red Army
but over the decades because of its
separation from the economic and
manufacturing centers of the country it
has slid into irrelevance laura liked so
many in his generation left home at a
young age to look for work in a major
city he ended up in sins in which is one
of china's tech hubs as the young
migrate these rural villages are left
with only elderly who are really
struggling to elevate themselves above
abject poverty after nine years Lord
decided a return to Jung XI in 2017
because he believed that the booming
ecommerce marketplace in China could
help him revive his village like many
rural communities Louis home specialized
in a very specific provincial craft
making fermented bean curd in this case
so he started a small factory and
started selling his locally made goods
online but been many years of
consumption growth across China's major
cities but recently the technology has
been driving an explosion in craft good
sales among China's middle and upper
classes WeChat and other e-commerce
platforms allow rural producers to
market and sell their goods far beyond
their original distribution areas
research companies actually track this
impact by Counting what is called tall
ball villages this is any rural village
where at least 10% of its households are
selling goods online and make a certain
amount of revenue and the growth has
been significant in the last few years
there were just 20 Taba villages and
212 in 2014 780 and 26th 2015
thirteen hundred and twenty 16 and over
2100 at the end of 2017
they now account for nearly half a
million active online stores 19 billion
dollars in annual sales and 1.3 million
new jobs created and Louis first year
back home he was able to employ 15
villagers and he sold about 60,000 units
of fermented bean curd he expects to
hire 30 more people in the next year as
his demand rapidly rises there are 60
million left behind children scattered
across China's rural landscape
and they grow up with at least one
parent far away from home as a migrant
worker alongside of the general
hardships of rural life they often have
to travel vast and dangerous distances
just to get to school they account for
30 percent of the country's primary and
high school students ten-year-old son
shin is one of these students
he walks an hour each way every single
day to school across these deep ravines
in an isolated landscape but when he
arrives at the small farming village and
gansu province he will find just two
other students in his entire school
that's Hong's school is one of a
thousand and guns who alone that is less
than five registered students so with
limited student interaction with
under-qualified teachers and school
houses that are barely furnished and not
insulated rural students have long been
disadvantaged with almost no path to
higher education but song's future has
been dramatically shifted with the
installation of a sunshine classroom
he's now part of a digital classroom of
a hundred students across 28 different
schools taught by qualified and
certified teachers live streaming from
hundreds of miles away he has access to
new subjects like music and art to new
friends and to experiences that extend
far beyond his home recently Chung even
got to visit the fredericksburg Castle
Museum in Denmark virtually of course
now online education has existed for
many years outside of China but it has
never reached truly transformative scale
likely because traditional education
systems and other tech centers of the
world are far more advanced and far more
stable but China's extreme terrain and
size have created an enormous and
immediate need for innovation there's a
tech startup in Shenzhen that grew to
300,000 students in just one year and by
our best estimation at the post there
are now 55 million rural students across
China that are addressable and
accessible by live-streaming classes
this market of need is larger than the
entire u.s. student population between
kindergarten and grade 12 so I'm
extremely encouraged to
doubt that private investment and EdTech
in China now exceeds 1 billion dollars a
year with another 30 billion dollars in
public funding that is committed between
now and 2020 as the Chinese Internet
continues to grow even in its
imperfection and restrictions and
controls the lives of its ones Forgotten
populations have been irrevocably
elevated there is a focus on populations
of need not of want that has driven a
lot of the curiosity the creativity and
the development that we see and there's
still more to come in America internet
population or penetration has now
reached 88 percent in China
the Internet has still only reached 56
percent of the populace that means there
are over 600 million people who are
still offline and disconnected that's
nearly twice the u.s. population an
enormous opportunity wherever this
alternative fuel exists be it in China
or Africa Southeast Asia nor the
American heartland
we should endeavor to follow it with
capital and with effort driving both
economic and societal impact all over
the world just imagine for a minute what
more could be possible if the global
needs of the underserved become the
primary focus of our inventions thank
you
[Applause]